No. What the
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
authored by the chapter chapter number
five the chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
observation
we have the
third narration
of the chapter
believe it is the third narration of the
chapter. Is it number three?
the narration. Yes, it is number
three. The narration of Abdullahb Abbas
and this narration
deals mainly with the topic of
decree. However,
and we've already mentioned this before,
but I think it warrants another go.
We mentioned that Iban Abbas is how is
he related to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is his cousin. Correct.
Is his first cousin it's his first
paternal cousin meaning on his father's
side. Now
we mentioned that he has four
uncles
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
What are their names?
Al Abbas
Abu Talib Hamza
and Abu Lahab. Correct. Abuab
Abuab's name is Abdul.
Abdul
that's his name Abdulahb.
So if we were to Abuahab is his all
right
and so his cousin Abdullahb Abbas
this man was an incredible
scholar and incredible mind and he was
referred to by the companions by other
major companions such as Ali Abbal
who is one of the most major scholars of
the companions in the history of Islam.
He referred to him as
the word
means the
scholar of the the scholar of the
but the word scholar doesn't really
capture the essence of the word
you know in the Arabic language
when
we have I want you to look at
the letters in the Arabic language. Each
letter a a chemical or an
element. You know that the chart of
elements, the elemental chart, right?
It has its particular parameters.
And then when you mix it with another
element,
you get a particular reaction. Okay? The
letters in the Arabic language are just
those elements
that when you put them in a together,
they have a reaction. Even if you change
the order of the letters,
they will always have the same reaction.
I'll give you an example. for
instance, the word.
What other word can you think of uses
those same letters? H.
Very good. Huh.
There's two
which means ocean, right? or C
we have also harp which is war.
Now
these letters always connect those three
words which is scholar
which is sea or ocean and harp which is
war. All three of these all root back to
the same general meaning. What is it?
Intensity and depth and immensity.
Right?
So
because we have alab is a scholar.
Bahar is an ocean is a sea.
Harp is a collection of people who are
fighting
a sea or an ocean. an immense huge
amount of soldiers. You wouldn't use the
word war or harb to describe two people
having a quarrel. This is armies which
are involved in these kinds of things.
And so all of these three
combinations of the same letters they
all articulate the same general meaning
and that is what
depth. They all articulate depth. They
all articulate huge amounts, huge
numbers. They all articulate
something that is immense. And that
is the meaning of hab
is a derivative of that same meaning of
bah which means
a scholar that is not only a scholar
but a scholar that is immense and deep
the ocean in his knowledge and rich
the not the ocean right and
that's why the Arabs use that same com
that same those same three elements
to
make up the word that is most
associated with scholarship and that is
what wordith
what is he inc that is most associated
with what with scholars
again we look at the Arabic letters as
elements on a chart.
and we could do this with any any
word really. Same thing with the wordh
and
right they all go back to the same even
though we change the order those
elements when you put them together
they're always going to have that same
reaction even if it is a different
variant. So this is something that
I'm not sure can be done with English
because English is not a Seemetic
language. It's not an original language.
It's a combination of many languages.
But Arabic is an original Seemetic
language. It has no beginning that is
known of. Right? Arabic and
Hebrew and Aramaic which are which
is really the the the grandfather of
Arabic and Hebrew.
the point is is that he is referred
to as
the scholar the immense
the scholar of the Muslim
Abdullahb Abbass. And this is curious
because Abdullahb Abbas
was born in Sheb
is the path in the mountains that belong
to Abu Talib that
Benu Hashim was exiled in for those
years in Mecca.
Do we know this story? The story of when
the Arab tribes got together because Abu
Talib would not allow them to harm his
nephew, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. He would not give him up to
be killed or exiled. And so they
decided, if you won't give him up, then
we will just excommunicate and exile all
of Benihashia, the whole tribe, all of
it. And so they had the tribes get
together
and agree
to not deal with Beni Hashim at all in
any way. And anyone who dealt with them,
anyone who sold them one grain
will be excommunicated and exiled as
well. And so Abu Talib
had a sheb. He had a piece of land on
the outskirts of Mecca which was
referred to as Shebal.
and
all of Benihashim, they resorted to that
valley and they remained there for a
number of years in famine and it was all
out famine because no other Arab tribe
was allowed to deal with them. If you
were a merchant and you came to Mecca to
sell whatever it is you were selling and
you went and and sold them something,
you would be made aware that these folks
are excommunicated.
Not one of them is allowed to buy
anything or sell anything. You're not
even allowed to give them anything.
You're not allowed to marry from them,
to marry to them,
nothing. The only thing they allowed is
people to visit visit their relatives.
But it was so bad that they had to sneak
loaves of bread. Women had to sneak
loaves of bread in their clothing
to smuggle it in to give to their you
know, whoever it is, their fathers or
their uncles or whatever it is, you
know, their daughters would be married
to other tribesmen and they would come
to visit
their father or their brother from
Beni Hashim and they'd have to smuggle
in loaves of bread and little portions
of food. And so it
became so bad that it was said you could
hear the whailing of children for miles
from hunger. It was so bad that they
were resorting to eating leather and
eating leaves off of trees. And they
actually wrote this agreement and it's
an embargo which is an act of war. and
they they hung it up in the Kaa
itself.
And so during that time they were
they that famine was over and that
excommunication was over in the 10th
year after Hijah.
the 10th year after Hijra or the ninth
year a little bit earlier that's the
same year that who passed away
Abu Talib and Khadijah so as soon as
they came out of that exile Abu Talib
passed away Khadijah passed away 10th
year the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasallam went on the greatest journey
which is But
in the 10th year, okay,
Iban Abbz was born in that 10th year
before or 10th year after prophethood.
So 3 years before Hijra,
he was born in that valley during the
exile period, during the famine period.
And so Abdullahb Abbass in the most
generous estimates
was how old when the prophet passed away
sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
what's the math? 13. That's the most
popular opinion. Some say 14. The most
generous opinion is that he was at most
15 years old when the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam passed away.
That means that most of his time
around the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam he was very very young
especially that he only came to Medina
with his father alb. his father at
Abbass became Muslim and made hijah to
Medina or moved to Medina much much
later much later after the conquest of
Mecca. And so this puts all of his time
that he spent with the prophet
sallall.aii
physically together collectively
at most six or seven years.
So he's very young.
But then you look at how many narrations
he narrated
over a thousand unique individual
narrations.
How is that possible?
This is possible because of something we
call
and we will talk about that tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]